the u.s is providing powerful support to
ukraine in its fight against russia
military equipment from the u.s and nato
allies is part of the reason ukraine's
military has had some success on the
battlefield but the biden administration
swiftly rejected a plan to transfer
soviet-era warplanes to the country from
poland weda jenga is at the white house
wija good morning
good morning to you nate and good
morning everybody you're right congress
just approved nearly 14 billion dollars
of humanitarian and military assistance
to ukraine but the biden
administration's refusal to support more
fighter jets to the country is drawing
fierce criticism from lawmakers on both
sides especially because it is a
reversal from what the secretary of
state said earlier this week
the motion to concur is agreed to on
capitol hill the spending bill which
included 13.6 billion dollars in aid to
help ukraine cleared the senate with
bipartisan support thursday night
still as the russian invasion enters
week three republicans have criticized
the biden administration for moving too
slowly this administration has been a
step behind every
every step of the way dozens of gop
lawmakers signed a letter to the
president imploring him to provide
defense air power to help save civilian
lives but the pentagon says it opposes
any plan for nato nations to provide
fighter jets to ukraine calling it quote
high risk because it could escalate
tensions it's coming across as
indecision and
bickering among
members of the administration
there also appears to be disagreement
over what to call russia's bombing of a
hospital maternity ward the u.s
ambassador to the united nations said
they constitute war crimes but the white
house has so far avoided that phrase we
need to go through the legal assessment
and review in order to make a formal
conclusion following reports that russia
may be considering seizing the assets of
u.s companies that suspended operations
there white house press secretary
jensachi tweeted that would ultimately
result in even more economic pain for
russia
president biden is also expected to call
today for the end of normal trade
relations with russia which will hike up
a lot of the import taxes for products
that come from there the u.s will be
joining the uk and european union in the
move it's another effort to [ __ ]
russia's economy dana
all right weeja thank you